[Applause]
Do not forget to check out cindi.com.
Brothers and sisters, one of my most
amazing clothing brands that I wear,
alhamdulillah, owned by Muslims with the
recent boycott that's going on with many
brands, clothing lines supporting
Israel. Brothers and sisters, you guys
know I've been supporting cindi.com.
I've been wearing their stuff long, long
time ago. Alhamdulillah. And I love
their clothing. Brothers and sisters,
it's exactly what I I like.
Alhamdulillah, when it comes to fitness,
training, jogging, just general wear
when I'm praying. I don't need to worry
about my back showing. Buy it for your
family members, your your uncles, your
brothers, your husbands, whoever it is,
inshallah, bro, sisters. Buy it for
yourself. Inshallah. It's modest
clothing wear.
two brothers and sisters and dear
friends. I came across this funny video
um of this I think he's an Indian Muslim
young kid who absolutely humiliates this
uh flipping pro Hindutwa BJP this uh
this bloody um fascist racist
Islamophobe uh party. So here is how it
goes and I just found it hilarious. It
just puts the guy in his place inshallah
alhamdulillah and you can see it just
speaks common sense inshallah. So let's
just quickly watch that and I hope you
find as funny as I do.
zindabadist
[Music]
[Applause]
Hindu
Muslim Hindu
Pakistan.
I found the last part so hilarious where
he goes he goes Who taught you this?
Yeah. He's trying to see like, you know,
learn from the Quran. Alhamdulillah is
from the Quran. Yeah. He goes, he goes,
I have a brain. You know, I thought that
so funny. Yeah.
Because he says the sound the sound mind
it doesn't go against the what Allahh
has revealed. So which means that that
man I he doesn't need Allah's created
him this young man to know justice.
Yeah. And Allah says if he saved one
soul he says if he saved the whole of
humanity. So he's basically saying look
uh long live India long live Pakistan
and he's like oh are you not ashamed
about the Pakist he goes I'm
saying long live each place that place
whoever place there's people living
there he's saying no one should be
harmed and he say no that basically it's
like what he's saying is an objective
truth yes and they say no no no no you
how could you say that Pakistan should
be destroyed it's like why not like
Pakistan should not be destroyed neither
should India be destroyed there's
Muslims there's Hindus there human
beings they should not be killed so he
say no No, no. Is are you not ashamed?
It's unbelievable. Subhan Allah. And
they are getting a this is this is a
printed um uh word for word manual book
that's given to them by design. Yes,
this is the same print book that's been
given to them by the design. They're
doing the same strategies, the same
moves, etc. And it's not working. And
it's not working. And it's very bizarre
because if you look into the Quran,
Subhan Allah, um those who were like,
you know, not all the Jews are the same,
alhamdulillah, but the Jews at the time
in Medina, they used to ally with the
Hindus. They went to the Hindus and they
would say to the Hindus, the Hindus, not
the Hindus, sorry, the pagans. Yeah.
Okay. In the um in Arabia. Yes. In
Mecca, they would go to them and say to
them, "Whose religion is superior?"
Okay. The the uh the Hindus will go
sake. The pagans would ask the Jews and
Jews say, "Yeah, your religion is
superior." When they know categorically
idolish worship is the worst. There's
even some Jews that believe that Muslims
um that they believe Muslims are um
subhan Allah that they they follow a
gentile prophet that we will go
paradise. Okay. So, subhan Allah, you
can see that Allah tells us about the
allyship and subhan Allah that's exactly
what's going on with Zionist
Zionism in Israel and in Hindu Hindutva
the BJP whatever they're called. Subhan
Allah. I found this hilarious
alhamdulillah and it just sums up in a
nutshell and hopefully I will get the
the privilege or should I say the badge
of honor of being banned in India.
Muhammed Jab has Zan has and
multin hopefully this will be a video
that I can also join the team because
I'm getting a bit jealous now. There
must be something I'm doing wrong. Why
are they all being banned but not and we
get banned in India inshallah and I
don't care. who will speak the truth and
like that boy did alhamdulillah
humiliating this presenter speak the
truth even if it's against yourself or
your kin inshallah alhamdulillah I'll be
living by this truth inshallah till the
day I die and coming days inshallah I
will be speaking about different truths
inshallah for those who know who know
inshallah time to break my silence
inshallah on that matter we'll see you
guys very
soon Pakistan zindabad